[Music]
entry backstabbing and secret plots the
brexit folks was unlike anything in UK
political history people are still
asking how did they all get it so wrong
on the night of the result the mood was
pretty buoyant could the PM have got a
better deal from the EU
why was the remain campaign such a
disaster and what was it like to be in
the room when Britain's role in the
world changed forever
we've talked the senior politicians
campaign chiefs and PR gurus to piece
together the inside story of how brexit
unfolded and to look to the future this
is how Britain lost the European plot we
are approaching one of the biggest
decisions this country will face in our
lifetimes whether to remain in a
reformed European Union or to leave back
to first principles this David Cameron
have to put Britain's EU future on the
line I'm afraid it'll go down as one of
the worst self-inflicted and harm that a
prime minister could do to himself ever
in probably British political history
and there was absolutely no need for it
whatsoever and having pulled it he
unleashed forces that he had no control
over and left us where we are today I
think he made the mistake of thinking
that it was in the bag and therefore not
really communicating to the other EU
leaders that there was any possibility
of a leap vote he was going to country's
the no British Prime Minister had being
T for a century and what he was
constantly were saying was a warning to
them look there is a lot of concern and
euro skepticism in Britain and we really
could leave the EU from the pro-european
point of view George Osborne said that
he was the absolutely last person to be
persuaded that it was desirable or
necessary and Michael goes from the anti
European point of view apparently told
Cameron for goodness sake don't do this
you'll split the party you'll split the
country it will have
completely unpredictable consequences
don't take the roof it became clear to
me in 2012 there would be a referendum
and of course that point when I think 81
conservative MPs rebelled to try a
fourth referendum is clear for that
point it would be one so we have to
start preparing the brexit us began
plotting their campaign in plain sight
and the Tate Britain gallery just half a
mile from Westminster
I took the view that if we met
sometimes we meet in the cafe here
sometimes we just go round and look at
the painting yes we never met a single
hack or a single MP despite the
plottings the PM was confident he could
win David Cameron embarked on a European
Odyssey intended to secure a better deal
for Britain in the EU a deal he could
sell in a referendum it turned out to be
an ill-fated mission and the thing that
was going to be acceptable to the
British people or convincing to the
electorate was not acceptable to EU
Potter's and I think that that is still
the case I think those who say you could
have got more you could have got an
emergency break or a capital immigration
I just don't think that was realistic
I'm convinced that the day that the
leave vote one was when the Prime
Minister came back without any powers
returned without even a new treaty and
we were obviously then saying look if
this is how we're treated now before we
had the vote how would we be treated if
we voted to say there's a sort of
industry in saying that he didn't
actually get a very good deal when he
went to the renegotiation he actually
got us out of ever closer Union but one
I think that our mistake probably was
was that we created a situation where
people had greater expectation than was
realistic here in Brussels there was a
general feeling that David Cameron had
got a good deal perhaps too generous a
deal and people thought he was going to
win his referendum inverses were
convinced that the deal that the UK has
in the EU waiver budget rebate with no
Schengen no Yahoo justice and police
cooperation and so on so forth it was
impossible to get a better deal outside
of these he said that
you would window repair again he was
completely it was pretty confident yes
diplomats tell me that had a g20 summit
in Brisbane in 2014
David Cameron claims he would win the
referendum by a margin of 70/30 did that
confidence undermine his negotiating
position could he have got a better deal
it was regarded as too generous because
I remember reading the newspapers and
they said you give everything to the
British and so they always have some
advantages in the end EU Cameron went
and asked for hardly anything and got
nothing and at that moment I said given
that I'm asked to cast my vote I cannot
be silent and I cannot endorse it he
asked for too little and then in the end
relied on mrs. Merkel delivering more
than she could ever do she's not going
to sacrifice European unity in order to
help David Cameron out of an internal
domestic political jam in Britain and in
his own party to come back and pretend
that we'd somehow renegotiated our
complete you know terms with the EU
I'm afraid just didn't back up Britain's
EU renegotiation was settled in February
2016 and the fight was on as the country
prepared for its referendum in June
Cameron's policy chief Oliver let win
was tasked with drawing up a sovereignty
bill that might persuade Boris Johnson
to campaign for remain the discussion
with Boris was a very lively the Duchess
went on for some some weeks and it was a
very interesting discussion to turn out
in the end
but it wasn't very useful because we
never got to the point of an agreement
that we could then have tried out one of
the big unknowns really is what would
have happened particularly Boris I mean
I think Michael Gove was both less
important than probably more predictable
but I think Boris was the was a big
unknown gameplan campaigned pretty
extraordinary in retrospect that right
up until those last few days that was in
he had lost Boris but Cameron still
thought he could destroy the leaf side
with a barrage of warnings about the
economic risks of brexit quickly the
campaign got bogged down the great
uncertainty that leaving the European
Union would bring as the Prime
Minister's and the Chancellor's
intervention which works relentlessly to
desire in their prognostication we're
not really being accepted they weren't
bringing in a trace by feeling there was
a growing resistance of the public they
weren't going to be bulldoze it in this
way they weren't going to be carpet
bombed into voting to keep Britain
inside the European Union the turning
point came on May the 27th and the
introduction of murder a government
machine was no longer allowed to work
for the remaining side and the leave
campaign unleashed his most powerful
weapon immigration the advantage of our
proposal is that you will be able to set
the right priorities for immigration
when you take back control there one or
two people on our side who were rather
complacent and said at the time we've so
won this economic argument we forced
them to go on to the immigration
argument there were those of us who felt
actually was always their game plan was
to go on immigration
then there were ministers who were told
and in no uncertain terms not to go out
and speak about it
there were appearances that were
canceled by number 10 and I think all of
this was deeply unfortunate David
Cameron decided he could not risk taking
on his opponents on the most salient
issue in the campaign
David Cameron could have brought that
entire debate to a complete halt by
saying I will veto the applications by
Turkey to become a member of the
European Union what he did is he could
think well of course the French will
veto which simply just added to our
argument of things even to something as
fundamental as Turkish application the
British Prime Minister is outsourcing
that responsibility to France
then came the decision by Cameron not
personally target Boris Johnson and
we've got right on our side for some it
was the biggest blunder in the brexit
story let's make sure that June the 24th
is Independence Day but Britain thank
you very much I was surprised they
didn't go after Michael Gove and Boris
Johnson ball to have to remain campaign
tried to lashes all in together and
basically say that Michael boris giller
Angie Bamford you know James Dyson are
all as bad as Nigel Faraj and his
friends and you kept that would have
been terminal to her thank you thank you
very much Trinity Henry College we were
reluctant to sanction blue of the
attacks for two reasons the small one is
that David Cameron wanted to bring the
Conservative Party back together at the
end of it and there's a more poison that
was pumped into the system that was
obviously going to be a problem
but the real reason was the more that
you were dealing in attack you are
basically feeding a beast which meant
that there would be endless media
stories about who would having a go at
who who was going to be the next leader
of the Conservative Party in there for
Prime Minister and that meant that you
were dragging the campaign off into
other territory that is not actually
about what you want to talk about why
it's sensible for Britain to say in the
EU in desperation Cameron and Osborne
ramped up warnings of a brexit calamity
including what leave memorably dubs a
punishment budget it backfired the
remain campaign never quite managed to
establish that total dominance on
economic issues that every time an
argument was made the leave campaign
were very affected either undermining
the messenger or just throwing enough
doubt in people's mind some of the
messaging particular to Levin was very
black and white and not unless credible
for that for me it was odd because you
know I'm apparently be you know one of
the inventors of message discipline and
keeping absolutely tight on a strategy
at a you know in a very sort of tight
knit communication but I never dreamed
of taking it to the extent literally of
saying absolutely nothing else about
anything and simply just saying the same
thing over and over and over again
especially when it manifestly wasn't
working one of the questions that
Peter Mandelson really struggles with
his that actually getting an influence
on the Labour Party to stick to the
message and stay with that method was a
real problem too
so if you are a leader of the left in
this country Jeremy Corbyn or Nicola
Sturgeon and you probably think that
remain will win there's very little in
it for you to be hugely supportive of a
conservative prime minister who in
normal day-to-day business is actually a
mortal enemy the murder of the Labour MP
Joe Cox by a man shouting Britain first
put the campaign on hold but it did not
change the course of history it would
see the toxic combination of Joe Cox's
murder with you kept appalling breaking
point poster and that combination I
thought was really taken the wind out of
our sails and there was a point that day
where I really thought thee was game
over we because know where we get our
momentum back and we start having that
inevitable swing back to the status quo
it wasn't just morally questionable to
be using that picture it was obviously
tactically disastrous for us not sure
Matthew Elliott is right in thinking
that vote leaves were the people who
actually want it I think Farraj actually
had a much greater impact than they're
prepared to accept or admit the poster
as I said I think personally I wouldn't
have run it if I'd have any charge of
the campaign but nevertheless it was
relevant to what was going on and it
wasn't appalling at all it reflected
what's happening to this country we got
this fantastic victory despite vote
leave not because of it it's all down to
you Kip and it's activists in the end
all Cameron and the remain campaign
could do was wait on the night of the
results I had a dinner for donors and a
which draws Osborne came and the mood
was pretty buoyant and we just had all
the opinion polls which showed us with a
clear lead and narrow lead but a very
clear consistent lead George Osborne was
nervous but sort of quietly confident
and as the night went on you kept hoping
that the cities were going to sort of
come to one's rescue and they never did
quite enough and by really three in the
morning
was absolutely clear we'd lost and by
that time the Mooseport bleak personally
I felt really desperately sad and it was
a sort of sense of almost disbelief that
we were doing this and of course though
it was also admit by the fact there were
a lot of young people who were really
distraught and you know many in tears
and so it was a it was a grim evening to
go to finally go to bed I argued that
David should say we had time quietly to
talk about what if and we talked about
both possibilities obviously if nobody
was sure whether we're going to win or
lose and I I strongly argued that David
should remain well well well the simple
grounds actually I thought was a person
who's best able to be Prime Minister the
United Kingdom his view was and other
people's room were very persuasive about
this but actually he would not be the
best person to lead it at that point
because he his credibility was too
damaged at that moment by having be on
the other side my view very strongly was
that if we lost he was going to have to
resign and the reality was I just didn't
think it would be sustainable in any way
for him to stay on and it was also the
right thing to do he didn't believe in a
brexit it would have looked a very
strange situation if somebody who
campaigned as hard as he had had stayed
on as Prime Minister and I also thought
it was a dignified thing to do nearly
six months after the vote to leave the
EU David Cameron's resignation Michael
Gove political assassination of Boris
Johnson and the anointment of Theresa
May as Prime Minister
how does brexit look now do you want the
government doesn't seem to realize is
the basic asymmetry of this relationship
there are 27 of them and one of us they
have a single market in which they take
huge pride and want to protect at all
costs quite rightly because economically
it's so important for Europe they don't
want to exclude us from it I mean they
see that we've decided to leave the
European Union but if we want to
negotiate our way back you know we can
do that so
we can't sort of have it all on our own
terms we can't have our cake and eat it
when you remember club or you have some
rights and you have obligations and you
can't just keep the right lounger not
the obligations I had a text message
from my son who said I won't say the
first text text message mother you've
just taken it out of the EU removed the
Prime Minister and about to take
trillions of the stock market will be
useful to know what you're doing
tomorrow
you're not jubilant about things like
that because you know these aren't
decisions which carries risks with them
but I was absolutely clear in my mind
that he was the right thing to have done
I've been working for this for 26 years
I couldn't have been happier and I
couldn't be more optimistic now I think
it's probably fair to say that in the
country at large there was some sense of
shell shock which I tell you what that
was it's the shock of finding yourself
back in control again it's the shot of a
convalescent who's bedridden for weeks
finally gets out of bed crosses the
floor throws the door open and drives
out into the garden and there is a
little moment of shock but my goodness
it's a good shot
what brexit will ultimately look like
remains to be seen but what is clear is
that the dramatic events of 2016 have
changed the course of British history
[Music]